and here's the thing this is
extraordinary last weekend it was this
manga it 45th anniversary of The
Godfather well that's right you all
gather I mean that must be extraordinary
because you were that was extraordinary
you were such different people 45 years
ago I was pretty much the same but
everybody else was different because you
know they're fantastic actors and of
course Francis was so articulate I wish
every could have been here and tell the
stories about what he went through to
make that movie and every single choice
that he made was just like a genius
choice and he had to fight for
everything I remember he was talking
about how they wanted to fire Pacino and
they wanted him out and he had shot
Francis had shot the early scenes where
we're just young and we're kind of he's
kind of insecure and they kept hating in
the studio and so what happened was that
Francis being a genius he said okay I'm
going to shoot this one scene and he
shot the scene so that they wouldn't
fire a Pacino of where Pacino kills the
cop you know with the Chino oh my god
and that scene Albertina is so great in
that scene it's so moving and you know I
hadn't seen the movie in 30 years so I
figured well I'm going to be there so I
took my computer out and I watched it on
computer and I have to tell you the
movie is genius yeah and you can't
believe it and it's all that Dan Francis
[Applause]
oh my god I it was great to be there
yeah you play what
it's huge kudos to you but it's not
interesting to hear about yeah you think
it's so good whirring ago I like the
audience more where Norton here if you'd
like to see even more stuff like that
that hit subscribe or toll free world
but I know what I do in that situation